- There's a million reasons why you know
the love of your life is
the love of your life.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I told Miss Sherwood, I said,
you wanna go out to dinner tonight?
She said, yeah.
I took her to a baseball
game for a baseball hot dog.
- Of course you did.
- And she was phenomenal.
- Yeah.
- She threw down the challenge.
And that little gal, I've gotta tell you,
when she turns it on, it's like,
she's she's the best man.
She's, what I love about her is she is,
she's a guy that's got
all the great girl stuff.
You know?
- Yeah.
- She is.
(Kelly Laughing)
- She's fabulous. She is fabulous.
She's the sports stud.
- She's a guy that that has
all the great girl stuff.
I love that. A best friend.
It's a best friend.